I think there are several issues one of
them is how to figure out how to get out
of Iraq in a in a in a respectable way
in a way which does not cause that place
to implode and does not cause that
region to deteriorate badly which which
could happen if we don't do it the right
way sooner or later we're not going to
be there just a question of how do you
get out in an orderly fashion in a
constructive way and and that it means
you can't do it overnight but you can't
delay it indefinitely because we'll just
simply be prolonging me the losses that
were suffering that's that's one area
the second and any new president is
going to have to deal with that any the
political process is going to have to
deal with that the second thing I think
is that the political process is going
to have to deal with are these reforms
changes in social security and medicare
and medicaid they're simply
unsustainable financially and it is i
think immoral to promise people things
that the government simply is not going
to be able to provide them either we
find ways of providing those benefits or
we trim them for people don't need them
to ensure the people who do need them
get them third the educational system
any political leader or any new
president any new leader and the
Congress is going to have to address
that issue notes tends to be a national
state and local issue more the national
issue and some states do a better job
than others but it but it is a national
issue and if we don't deal with it at
the state and local level it's going to
undermine our society and undermine our
our economic system and undermine our
global competitiveness I think we also
have to be straight with American people
about the threats to American security
what they are how we have to deal with
them through improved Homeland Security
or improved capability in the military
or improve intelligence capabilities
things of that nature and be very candid
with people about these kinds of things
and also to make a major effort to deal
with energy and the question of hothouse
of greenhouse gases and things of that
nature I mean that's get that whole
energy issue the green issue is
important it's a national security issue
to reduce our dependence on imported oil
and it's and it's an issue of avoiding
carbon emissions which over a period of
time are leading to global warming and
that is going to be a big issue and I
think our grandchildren if we don't deal
with this issue are going to say why did
you leave us with this horrible legacy
of a economy that's dependent more more
on a poor loyal from countries that many
of which are unreliable and why did you
leave us with a system so dependent on
hydrocarbons that we have to make the
choice between not using the
hydrocarbons and the economy weakening
or using them in causing more more
deterioration of the environment we have
to come up with alternatives we have to
come up with them very quickly that
takes money that's going to take a
commitment of large sums of money and
the government is going to have to be a
key not the only but a key provider of
that if we are so myopic so
short-sighted that we can't understand
this then again we're leaving
a terrible legacy to future generations
and if you go back to the family father
as the point I made earlier they thought
about their posterity very few
politicians today are thinking about
their posterity about coming generations
some are but too few